in a world / chaos facing Cataclysm only
one man can save the universe coming
this summer the first revenger
his name is Adam arrow
[Music]
[Applause]
honestly I feel like I've got the gist
testicles in a history of mankind hello
and welcome to Playstation grenade I
don't know if you've noticed but there
is a new game mode to play a limited
time game mode in fortnight battle
royale and yes Thanos is back so I
thought we'd jump in and we just mess
about and see what happens see what kind
of people we meet and what shenanigans
we can get into let's do this we're in
we're in this is a new game mode I'm
ready for it music this is good music
get you in the mood please be the shield
please with the shield we want to
Captain America the crap out of this
game I see gorgeous little bugger run
quick huh let's block what the hell did
that go sure this is gonna be epic epic
and behind you
comeback shield yes
oh this is so good in your face face are
you gonna friend
oh right let's try some tactics what
would I in my will take the high ground
I was above you the whole time
all three weapon types it comes back
it's like a boomerang actually legit
feel really sorry for you there dude
it'll be sat there thinking check out my
bells I have got this sorted then
suddenly right up the rectum it's gotta
hurt why are we still here
just suffer let's do some myth-busting
can we use Thor's hammer or axe or
whatever the hell it is
dawn breaker is an axe and can we jump
from this to that from this jack
to that Jack what say you you have five
seconds to decide
come anticlimax on with the game
27:11 there 26 left after this tiny
snowballs box oh my word
let's legit the greatest thing I've ever
done lucky it went right on though it
was so good it was such I'll show you
way up so as he starts building is one
by one there's a tiny gap at the bottom
to see sweet the shot is off
it's a letterbox can he get him before
the floor is made it's in and it hits
him just before the floor is made I am
never gonna do something that good ever
again in my life
I love you of em cyst
yeah
I need to work on my commentaries just
lots of noises at the moment oh they're
going your way okay so that's just a
throwaway clip but someone got in touch
after that match via Twitter and said
this hey just saw your name on the end
game match and I was trying to show you
some love so I went back in and tried to
find that chat was called kupo and yeah
he's right for a split second in that
clip he does start dancing what a guy
who says we can all get along are you
going brother is the ball causing you
issues
this is coming out of his misery that's
like 400 next time don't let the wall
beat you I need it wall joke here come
on
[Music]
how do Mexicans feel about Trump's wall
I don't know
but they'll get over it code a damn
arrow in the font night shop just gonna
see what daddy fancies doing what does
he do what he's not on the set of
Avengers and game oh there he goes yes
Daddy oh of some Burning Man with you
he's got balls like the chin tweak
panels it's tennis it's all stories on
its way
sorry papa we gotta go to work
Roman reigns I'm coming for you Roman oh
whoa that could have been worse that
literally killed him just does it hit me
if you're on the enemy team and you're
not fan offs this is boring as hell
oh he's in the tree all right tactics
change let's play the tree game with
good old alter aim on these stupid
bloody gloves
yeah you know this is how the real film
end game is going to finish Tony Stark's
stood in a tree killing them from any
distance and he'll die I want to cry
leti one hit I am for I'm lady Thor I am
for knock knock can I interest you in
the word of Jesus come on family toss
was the Greek god of death you can't see
me I'm invisible I'm invisible Captain
America lady if she's legit can't see me
I'm invisible it was hell upon her on
your face yeah run you better run I see
you around these pots again but right
what did I miss nothing at all oh there
may be an advantage to arriving late
could this be my first ever use of a
palace
holy [ __ ] this is so close please
please please please please
yeah this is mine and the first thing we
must do we've got to do some bunny hop
in well bang out some other dances in a
minute let's see if we can get some more
of these chitara chitara Chikara
shooters
enter shikari these things come down to
him boys dance be a daddy the hole they
all left me know we have to do now me
made-up meme it up nobody cares and that
off
what would fellows do in his day out
definitely till the towers for this stop
the pawnshop a word he can't open doors
with Thanos god damn it man oops sorry
okay sorry send me a bill next and
hosting holes for his favorite taco
right don't punch it shoot it now don't
shoot the kitchen bloody bloody blog get
out of them stupid way
now how about enough avenges you're all
dying now
the man Titan you can delight in your
little huts little piggy come on all of
you at once
1920
boys bring on the cannon fodder
whoops okay over jumped over jump I'm
still getting used to this map toys and
stuff I'll be there soon
26 more revenge's
we wore 27 avenges 28
I can pick it up
so I think this is my last life will
never happen
32 Oh taking too many bullets now let's
get a win soon go out fighting 34 please
let me pick it up please let me pick it
up oh that was so good
beam Thanos is so good it's been the
guitar do ever the cold Shakira's there
is that he's not fun but being Thanos or
being an Avenger is damn good so you've
made it to the end of another one of
these Saturday shenanigans thank you
very much I'm hugely appreciate it like
Yugi wolf will finish with a dance this
time it's Thanos this is a real serious
occasion this is for all those people
who've used my code in the font night
shop I hugely appreciate it you're all
again do you know that already but I'm
gonna keep saying it because I really do
appreciate it I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade think about using kodada Maru
and I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]